have you heard about Stephanie Meyer's
newest book Midnight Sun it may just
change the way that the entire series
turns out and the special effects have
to be better than that CGI baby that was
creepy enough for the crew to name it
after Chucky this is everything that you
want to see in the new Twilight series
so do you remember the creepy CGI baby
from Breaking Dawn Part 2 well it could
have been worse originally they'd wanted
an animatronic doll to stand in for the
half human half vampire baby except the
doll was so horrifying that it earned
the name Chuck has made after Chucky
from the child's play series if you
couldn't figure that out they knew right
away that they couldn't use this no one
was gonna believe that's the baby of
Robert Pattinson and Kristen Stewart and
so the decision to CGI over it was sort
of a last minute fix that even director
Bill Condon would admit didn't work out
he referred to the special effects as a
disaster but expressed optimism that
something like that probably wouldn't
happen if he were to do it again we hope
that this means that they can find a
better way to give us Renesmee in the
series because let's be honest there's
not much that could be worse than this
and yet the special effects aren't the
only concerns that we have for Renesmee
do you know what imprinting is in the
Twilight Universe you may not want to
it's what happens to a werewolf when
they meet their soulmate and the Woof in
question cannot live if something
happens to other person sounds sweet
right almost as sweet as subscribing to
our channel would be so maybe you should
just take a moment to do that right now
because getting back to imprinting for a
minute here it sounds all fun and games
until Jacob imprints on baby Renesmee
and Breaking Dawn yeah it may just be
better for the series to avoid bringing
up this plotline altogether it's one of
the more controversial aspects in the
Twilight franchise for sure and if
they're gonna mention it we hope that
they at the very least find a way to
make it come across less predatory
because as it is imprinting is really
not a good look and neither is Edward
watching Bella while she sleeps we've
all heard the criticisms against
Twilight many complained that Bella was
weak and we have to admit there are a
few red flags in her relationship with
Edward for one thing what's with the
whole bit I like watching you sleep
that's not normal and are Edwards mood
swings supposed to be attractive in a
lot of ways Edward acts more like a
stalker than a supportive boyfriend when
he envelopers meet and if we're gonna be
rebooting this franchise then they need
to address that the easiest way would
probably be writing Edward's stalkerish
Tendencies out entirely although they
might be able to do something by playing
more with Edward's perspective and if he
is gonna be up to his old Shenanigans
can we at least have a version of Bella
that's willing to call him out a more
empowered Bella would go a long way
towards making this series did you know
there's been a new Twilight book since
the last movie yeah midnight sun and
Stephanie Meyer published it on August
4th 2020. like it basically just follows
the same plot as the first Twilight book
except it's all from Edward's point of
view it fills in all those pesky little
questions you've been asking yourself
off like what was Edward doing all those
times he went on hunts and what was he
really thinking the first time he saw
Bella it's a great read for anyone
looking for a more complex breakdown of
the Twilight lore but we're wondering
how Midnight Sun could affect this
series the series could go back and
forth between Edward and Bella's
perspective adapting both Twilight and
Midnight Sun at the same time which
would definitely be interesting to see
but of course we all know Stephanie
Meyer won't be the only writer involved
there's another reason Twilights come
under Fire in recent years this one has
to do with Jacob and the big reveal that
he's a werewolf because he's a member of
the quill youth tribe this might be okay
if it weren't for the fact that the
quillute tribe is a very real tribe
there are around 2 000 people in western
Washington who call the tribe home and
they aren't werewolves or anything but
they have seen a very real effect from
this strained representation if we're
going to have a new Twilight series then
it'll need to be a lot more respectful
to the quillute tribe this time around
one huge step towards this would be by
hiring indigenous writers so that we get
an authentic voice from the indigenous
characters in fact a more diverse
Writing Room in general would probably
be for the best with this series
considering Twilight hasn't had the best
history with these things do you
remember Jasper's backstory in both the
books and the movies he was a
confederate soldier while the train in
the Confederate Army gave me is useless
against the newborn who was taken in by
a woman raising a vampire Army Maria
yikes you guys sure you're committed to
that whole confederate soldier bit it
wouldn't be so bad if the story didn't
frame it as if he were one of the good
guys if the series is going to insist on
keeping him as a confederate soldier
then at the very least we'd like to see
this lead to some sort of meaningful
conversation or character development
for Jasper both the books and the movies
sort of brush it off as if it were no
big deal but in our current political
climate we can't imagine it going down
the same way but if they're going to fix
Jasper's backstory there's another way
they could go about doing that the
series needs a more diverse cast this
time as much as we'd love to see some
familiar face cases the fact that the
colons are all mysterious well-traveled
vampires who form an adopted family
gives us a lot of wiggle room and this
was apparently something the director
Catherine Hardwick wanted to take
advantage of while casting for the first
movie she pushed for a more diverse cast
suggesting things like Alice be Japanese
but Stephanie Meyer shot her down as
Catherine put it she probably just
didn't see the world that way
considering the characters she'd written
had all been described as being white in
the books and we definitely want to
respect the author's wishes but we still
think that a more diverse cast would
give us a lot more interesting
conversations between our characters I
was the youngest major in the Texas
Cavalry especially when it comes to
issues like Jasper's backstory now while
we're on the subject of the cast there's
another thing we'd like to see from them
some cameos the original cast of the
movies did such a great job and while
we've come to live with the sad
knowledge that we won't likely be seeing
them reprise their roles in the series
that doesn't mean they can't appear in
other ways imagine Kristen Stewart
playing one of the vampires that joins
the Cullens in their war against the
Volturi or Taylor Lautner as one of the
teachers at Forks High School there are
plenty of opportunities for us to be
able to see some old faces again and
we'd love to see how the series might
fit them in the Twilight franchise is no
stranger to cameos anyway considering
the first movie included this shot of
author Stephanie Meyer sitting in the
diner now if only the first movie had
paid closer attention to their pacing
then they had to cameos let's be real
here not a whole lot happened in the
first Twilight book this is a detail
that's as loved as it is hated about the
series but it's definitely a problem
when you consider just how late into the
story the villains get introduced if
we're going to have Twilight as a series
then we're going to need to get our bad
guys doing something a bit earlier on
the movie did this well by sprinkling in
a few scenes of our villains hunting
it's always the same inning questions
who are you what do you want but we
would definitely like to get more of a
sense of the vampire World being a
threat in this series they're going to
have to be careful with how they do it
so as to not Rob Twilight of the thing
that gave it its charm to begin with but
we're still excited to see how the
series can flesh them out this entry is
sort of contrary to what we've said
before as much as we would like to see
some better pacing and a better sense of
what the villains want in the series we
also need a lot of moments that are just
from a teenage girl's perspective in
some ways the bad pacing of the book was
sort of a good thing because it gave us
a lot of time with Bella just trying to
be a normal teenager or about as you can
get when you're crushing on a 108 year
old vampire we'd like to see this series
fully dive into these feelings and stay
away from becoming the sort of
action-packed teen vampire shows we've
already gotten with the Vampire Diaries
or True Blood instead Twilight needs to
be about Bella's experience and we'd
like to see that maintained throughout
the series so between between a more
empowered heroin and better special
effects there are plenty of ways that
this new series could be even better
than the movies what did you think of
our requests for the Twilight series and
is there anything you'd like to see that
we didn't mention make sure to let us
know in the comment section down below